horror movies aren't always the ones to
sweep award shows but there are plenty
of gems that deserve recognition one
thing's for sure you'll never look at a
casual hookup the same way here are a
few horror movies that are terrifyingly
good
rosemary's baby is a master class when
it comes to building suspense but unlike
modern filmmakers who use mystery to
create tension director roman polanski
lets us know almost immediately that
there's something satanic happening in
the bramford apartment building when
rosemary woodhouse played by mia farrow
gets pregnant after a trippy evening
full of stripped-down seniors evil eyes
and mysterious scratch marks we know
there's something wicked growing in her
womb she starts craving raw meat her
skin goes pale and her creepy neighbors
won't leave her alone and while rosemary
doesn't understand what's happening the
audience is totally aware the devil is
in the details but the lack of mystery
doesn't detract from the suspense in
fact it makes things even more
unbearable as roger ebert wrote in his
review when the conclusion comes it
works not because it is a surprise but
because it is horrifyingly inevitable
rosemary makes her dreadful discovery
and we are wrenched because we knew what
was going to happen and couldn't help
her
what have you done to him
for a genre that's often about blood and
guts horror movies can be terribly
terribly sad when it comes to tragedy
few are more depressing than brian de
palma's carry past all the pig blood and
psychic powers carrie is a tale about a
lonely soul an outsider who's bullied so
badly that she finally breaks [ __ ]
spacek gives one of the best
performances in horror history as carrie
white starting off as a terrified teen
morphing into a happy girl with a great
big smile then turning into a wide-eyed
telekinetic killer de palma is on top of
his game here creating a high school
world that feels like something out of a
dream before exploding into a full-blown
nightmare the prom bloodbath is
ingenious in its editing and camera work
with the director using every trick in
the book from slow motion and split
screens to lighting techniques straight
from the italian jello films the result
is a movie that's horrific to watch both
for the fright factor and the
heartbreaking loneliness
horror fans love to debate which movie
was the first real slasher film was it
bay of blood or the texas chainsaw
massacre or perhaps black christmas
whatever gory flick got things started
halloween took the slasher mainstream
released in 1978 this brutal little
thriller laid the groundwork for every
masked killer movie to come but few have
captured the original's evil essence
who can forget that horrific synth score
the moment you hear the halloween theme
you've got to look over your shoulder to
make sure there's no one stalking you
then there are the chilling visuals like
the iconic pov tracking shot of michael
making his first kill or the glimpse of
the shape lurking in lori strode's
backyard it's all so simple yet it hits
something so primal but really the
longevity of halloween comes down to the
man in the william shatner mask he's the
personification of evil cinema's biggest
boogeyman and no matter how many times
you shoot him michael just keeps coming
most serial killers keep some sort of
trophies from their victims
i didn't
no
no you ate yours
there aren't any vampires or werewolves
in the silence of the lambs instead this
oscar-winning thriller is all about real
life monsters hannibal lecter and
buffalo bill are terrifying because they
could actually exist when lecter stares
straight into the camera you're looking
into the eyes of a genuine demon a
monster you could actually meet on the
streets of course that's not to say the
silence of the lambs is filmed with any
sort of docu-realism jonathan demm's
movie is steeped in gothic horror
hannibal's dank cell and buffalo bill's
dungeon look like the lairs you'd find
in an edgar allen poe story the acting
matches the grim style with anthony
hopkins giving an electrifying
performance as the world's most charming
psychopath jody foster provides the
perfect counterbalance as clarice
starling gritty ambitious inexperienced
but strong but while killer cannibals
are always scary the real horror of the
film is what it's like to be a woman in
a male dominated world dem uses his
unique camera work and incredible
composition to show starlings surrounded
by intimidating dudes from squaring off
with a room full of cops to her
nightmare showdown with buffalo bill but
she never backs down from anybody and
her deathly dance with hannibal makes
for one of the most twisted
relationships ever seen on the big
screen
take ridley scott's cold directing style
hr giger's organic and graphic designs
and sigourney weaver's talent and you've
got the freakiest sci-fi movie ever made
released in 1979 alien is a terrifying
movie everything you see on screen you
can just about feel on your skin from
the xenomorph slimy mouth to the
facehugger's strangling tail everything
in this movie is so grimy and violent
and the alien design if you'll pardon
the pun is out of this world the
xenomorph feels like something that
could exist in real life and those
gruesome gigger creations let the movie
play with their deep-seated fear of
parasites the idea of a creature
crawling around your innards is truly
disgusting so when the alien pops out of
kane's chest it's still one of the most
memorable horror scenes ever filmed but
with all that monster talk let's not
forget about weaver as ellen ripley
while she became an icon in the sequel
ripley establishes herself here as a big
time monster hunter whether she's
suiting up for battle or creeping
through hallways with flamethrower in
hand she's a horror hero for the ages
surrealism can be pretty disturbing and
boy did wes craven know it while a
nightmare on elm street doesn't often
get mentioned with films like hershey
and lou or mulholland drive this right
flick is a masterpiece of surrealist
horror after all it's about a serial
killer who gets you in your sleep and as
the film goes on craven blends the dream
world with reality leaving you to wonder
where the waking life ends and the
nightmare begins with his ratty sweater
and demonic glove freddy krueger is one
of the most frightening monsters to
haunt the silver screen and that's
because when you fall asleep he becomes
your god just like an actual dream there
are no rules in freddy's world a bathtub
can open up into a bottomless pit stairs
turn into sticky goo and when the dreams
start bleeding into the real world
that's scary surrealism at its finest
directed by bong joon ho the host tosses
the spielberg rulebook out the window
ever since jaws most creature features
have kept their beasties off screen
until midway into the movie but the host
isn't playing by hollywood rules the
amphibious critter with clumsy legs
limber tail and toothy mouth shows up in
the first few minutes kicking off one of
the greatest monster attacks in horror
history on top of the awesome creature
design this korean movie works as a
family drama and a goofy comedy long
junho has always been a master of
balancing disparate tones and he juggles
them here with the greatest of ease
making us laugh then scream then weep
the film also works as a political
satire casting a snide glance at the
media military and politicians both
korean and american but the movie's
heart is a bizarre family searching for
a little girl kidnapped by the creature
and dealing with government figures sure
they can't stop arguing for more than
five minutes but these bickering weirdos
have a whole lot of heart and when they
finally face the beast you'll be on the
edge of your seat cheering as the
molotov cocktails start to fly
horror comedy is hard so many would-be
chillers end up stumbling over their own
goofiness mixing horror and humor can be
challenging unless your name is sam
raimi the man behind the evil dead
franchise raymie is a master at blending
fear and fun but not many people
appreciate drag me to hell that's a real
shame because this 2009 film is pitch
perfect when it comes to melding dark
humor with genuinely disturbing horror
the plot follows a young woman played by
alison loman who's been cursed by a
vengeful old woman played by lorna raver
in three days christine will be dragged
to hell and until then she'll be haunted
by a powerful demon this simple plot
lets remy indulge all his gross out
horror urges from eyes popping out of
cakes to muddy cemeteries it's a great
big goofy romp with a foul-mouthed goat
and evil dead fights but raymie pulls no
punches when it comes to the scares and
drag me to hell features one of the most
frightening endings you'll ever watch
through your fingers
directed by nao hong jin the wailing is
an epic horror film in every sense of
the word running close to three hours
long this korean tale is a biblical
battle of good versus evil there's
something devilish going down in a tiny
korean village a plague that involves
illness madness and murder an
incompetent cop played by quack dog is
determined to get to the bottom of
things especially when his little girl
starts showing signs of demonic
possession but unlike the stories of old
there's no guarantee that light will
defeat darkness the movie sits at a
crossroads of religions and cultures
some characters wear crosses to ward off
the devil while others rely on ancient
korean traditions some suspect a
mysterious japanese man living out in
the woods is at fault but is that just
historical prejudice coming into play
and how far do you go to solve a mystery
when human lives and their souls are on
the line at its heart the whaling is a
film about doubt versus faith one that
features an unstoppable zombie rabbit
killers a horrific hellhound and one of
the most disturbing exorcisms ever put
to film
horror movies love being ambiguous are
the ghosts real or is it all in your
head and when it comes to that kind of
eerie ambiguity there are few movies as
freaky as the babadook directed by
jennifer kent this australian film
revolves around a single mom named
amelia played by essie davis who's
dealing with the death of her husband
plus a very disturbed little boy played
by noah wiseman amelia has been trapped
in her grief and depression for a while
and things only get worse when the
babadook knocks at her door he's a top
hat wearing demon with his own pop-up
book the personification of emilia's
depression and as she falls deeper into
the darkness the babadook grows stronger
much like the shining the babadook wants
you to discuss its cryptic ending and
try to figure out what's real and what's
not is there a literal evil spirit
trying to possess emilia is it symbolic
of the endless pain she's got locked
away well the best thing about the
babadook is that the answer is yes
and i know you're in pain and i wish i
could take that away for you i wish i
could shield you from the knowledge that
you did what you did but your sister is
dead
hailed as the scariest movie in 2018
hereditary is certainly frightening and
it features one of the most twisted
endings in horror history but this film
is far more than just scares and screams
it's an extremely disturbing look at the
destructive powers of grief the
heartbreak that comes with being in a
family and the crippling power of mental
illness yes there are seances spirits
and the world's creepiest cult yes the
movie will keep you checking your
ceilings for months to come and yes that
scene involving a sketchbook and the
fireplace will leave your jaw all the
way on the floor however hereditary's
real power comes from the sense of doom
that lingers over the entire movie that
no matter what you do you can't escape
what's coming just like tony collette
creating miniature dolls and tiny rooms
it sometimes feels like your whole life
is being manipulated no matter how hard
you try to escape your past the things
you inherit will haunt you forever
if you've ever watched a slasher film
you'll know only virgins get out alive
if the monster catches you doing the
deed he'll introduce your face to mr
machete but writer director david robert
mitchell decided to play with that old
cliche in it follows a horror film where
having sex can actually kill you but can
also keep you alive this 2014 film
involves a young girl played by micah
monroe who contracts a supernatural std
unless she passes it along she'll be
killed by a shape-shifting monster and
if she dies the creature will hunt down
the guy who gave it to her and so on and
so on it feels like an actual urban
legend one accompanied by an incredible
synth score from disasterpiece but this
film is far scarier than any creepypasta
that's because the titular monster is
one of the most terrifying in recent
memory sure it's slow
but it's unstoppable you can't reason
with it you can't outrun it like death
it just keeps coming you never know when
you never know how but rest assured it
will stagger interviews sooner or later
it's inevitable as old age and
relentless as time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]